When I got into standard 10 years
ago, the question of what constitutes
a wincon was one with a single stand-out
answer—Aetherling. It was a control meta,
no doubt—if you weren’t playing a devotion
deck or attempting in vain to play green,
you were playing one of the many variants of
control, and you were almost certainly running
one or two copies of Aetherling as a way to
close out the game. For a relatively new player,
it was a comforting type of card—you input a bunch
of mana and two or three turns, and in return,
it reduces your opponent’s life total to
zero. So that’s what a wincon is, right?
Or maybe a wincon is when my brother played
an Overwhelming Stampede into a cluttered
boardstate to cut through my modest suite of
blockers like a hot knife through, I dunno,
a handful of 4/4 vampires. Or maybe it was
a wincon when I played Angelic Gift on a 4/4
land at the Battle for Zendikar prerelease
and smacked my opponent four times for the
win. Above average two mana enchantment,
honestly, some might even call it a wincon.
We all come across the concept of a win condition
somewhere along the line in our existences as
magic players. And this is for a reason—MTG’s
defense-friendly combat system and hand-emptying
mana system means that it can’t always be assumed
that the game will end naturally, that there are
all sorts of game situations that might sprawl out
and demand some sort of remedy. There are lots of
situations where the phrase “win condition”
has a fairly understandable meaning. However,
as with most pieces of terminology, it becomes
a lot more challenging in Commander. Sextupling
the life total of your opponents makes a lot of
things challenging, to be honest. Not only does
it take more to win in an EDH game, but the
concept of what winning means shifts wildly.
Conventional EDH wisdom might have you gesturing
at various things as a wincon—Craterhoof Behemoth
is a wincon, Torment of Hailfire is a wincon,
Purphoros, God of the Forge is a wincon,
Sanguine Bond is a wincon. And sure, this
classification does work on some level—there
are lots of situations where these cards will
win you the game, and they each gesture at a
different plan for winning the game. But is this
a useful category of card? I don’t think it is.
Anything can win a game—if your opponents play no
cards, a 1/1 squirrel is a quality wincon. If your
opponents are playing nothing but archers and
bears, a single Siege Dragon is a great wincon.
You shouldn’t ask the question “what cards in my
deck are the ones that win the game,” because the
important question is “what cards in my deck are
the ones that don’t win the game?” Now, let me
clarify that last statement—what I don’t mean to
say is that you should cram your deck full of big,
splashy bombs—quite the opposite. Having too high
a density of splash in your deck will leave you
too little room for the building blocks that
actually lead to victory. What I mean here is
that, if you’re building a deck with the intent
of winning a game of commander, that goal should
be present in some form or other throughout
each and every one of your card choices.
The number one criticism I have for people
when they ask me to look at their deck,
a criticism I give about half the time, is
“this looks unfocused.” This phrase can mean a
couple different things in practice, and to start
thinking about those, it’s useful to first lay out
a framework for how EDH decks work. Fundamentally,
most decks involve a system of inputs and outputs,
with inputs being conditions that need to be
met and outputs being results of those inputs
that contribute to the deck’s gameplan. My Sharuum
deck’s primary inputs are Astral Slide and cycling
cards, and its primary outputs are flickers,
which allow Sharuum to recur large artifacts
onto the board. My Meria deck’s primary inputs
are equipments, and its primary outputs are mana,
value, and my commander hitting your face
for 14 damage. I could give more examples,
but long story short, inputs and outputs
are the name of the game for decks with
any amount of synergy, and this framework itself
points us to the two places a deck can stumble
with regard to focus—it can have unfocused
inputs, and it can have unfocused outputs.
For an example of a deck with unfocused inputs,
a viewer emailed me about their Missy deck that
contained both artifact creature and
facedown creature synergy packages,
with a couple narrower sections of sub-synergies
within these. Within the deck there are the
components to make some decently powerful
boardstates, but the issue is that there
are too many different types of card and ability
present, and they don’t really connect with each
other outside of all being related to the
commander in some form or other. Ultimately
a deck like this with unfocused inputs will
naturally have lots of dead draws, and will
struggle to put together a cohesive boardstate
with any consistency. It’s possible to build a
deck that can pivot between a few different plans,
but these decks are tricky to build, and typically
involve paying close attention to points of
connectivity between various types of card.
Some examples of decks with unfocused
outputs would be conventionally built
variants of what I like to call value-tribal
commanders, and I’ll use Gavi, Nest Warden as
an example since I’ve already talked about her
before. Your average Gavi deck is pretty good
at maintaining cycling-based value loops,
but when we look at the actual payoffs for
cycling aside from draw, it’s a lot of small
token creation, some larger token creation,
some soft creature removal, some incremental
damage, some creatures getting bigger,
and so on. Theoretically you’re getting a lot
of stuff when you add the input of cycling,
but those outputs are so diverse that these
decks don’t end up actually doing any one
thing in particular—it’s just a flood of generic
Magic: the Gathering gameplay. This is probably
better than a deck with unfocused inputs because
it’s actually doing something pretty consistently,
but it’s a generally toothless type of deck
that will struggle to win against decks that
have more refined win plans, even if those decks
generate a smaller quantity of total resources.
Both unfocused inputs and unfocused outputs
are problems that will lead to challenges
in ending the game, but for different
reasons. Despite this, the solution to
the two problems is pretty similar—you should
be asking what each card in your deck does,
how often it will fail to perform its intended
function, and whether it contributes toward a
cohesive plan for your deck. A common first
step in building commander decks is to lump
together a bunch of cards that synergize around a
particular one or two things, and while this will
lead to a deck that does do something, if you’re
trying to win games it might take a bit of tuning
beyond that to make sure that a deck can actually
make it to the finish line. And for a bit, I want
to zoom in on a particular type of deck that
often falls just a little short in this regard.
Alright, this is a transition point in a
longer video where it might make sense to
put a midroll ad, but I don’t like midroll ads
so I don’t run them on my videos. That said,
if you like what I do and have a spare
three bucks a month to support me in making
high effort videos like this one, there’s a
link to my patreon down in the description.
As I was going through the EDHRec page for
Gavi while writing the previous section,
there was one standout exception to the
lack of good options for closing out the
game—that being Moonshaker Cavalry. The
card is a brutally efficient finisher,
capable of converting a board full of tokens
into a bunch of dead opponents in short order,
and its presence here gestures at a specific type
of card, mass buff cards, whose usage could lead
to a Gavi deck with a more definite identity.
This brings me to the subject of midrange—which
I’ll define here as decks that want to get a big
board of creatures and then attack with them. Now,
I’m sure when playtesting we all like to imagine
the ideal scenario for a beatdown deck—we play
out a bunch of creatures, and swing big into
the empty boards of our quivering hypothetical
opponents. And this might occasionally be
the case, but in most games, your opponents
will have creatures as well, even if their
deck isn’t a purely midrange deck. So here,
I’m going to introduce an important phrase—parity.
Parity basically means a state of standstill,
and in the midrange context it’s usually when
multiple players have decent-sized boards,
but can’t swing in for large damage due to a
lack of evasion or a risk of counterattack.
In a game like this with multiple midrange-y
decks, we can divide the game into two key
steps for a given player—“create parity”
and “break parity”. Creating parity just
means getting your beefy midrange board up and
going. This sounds simple, and indeed it’s not
too hard in the abstract, but there are lots of
places to go wrong. You can fail to draw mana,
fail to draw beaters, fail to draw
the right combinations of beaters,
and even if you succeed at these three things you
can still get board wiped or lose to a non-combat
wincon before you’re able to do an adequate
quantity of beating. For this reason, lands,
ramp, draw, protection, and a varied mixture
of creatures might all be parts of how you
get into a state of parity with other decks.
Breaking parity is where you do something to
the board that allows you to deviate from the
state of parity, which generally means letting
your creatures hit for a lot of damage. The
most popular parity breakers in commander
are overrun effects, but there’s a myriad of
potential other options—targeted buffs, goad,
extra combat spells, mass evasion spells, and
cards that disable potential blockers, or even
remove them altogether. I am on the record saying
that Mass Calcify is the best evasion spell.
Now, if I were to rank these in terms
of raw power, the bigger overrun effects
like Craterhoof Behemoth and Finale of
Devastation would be easily top of the pile,
with Moonshaker Cavalry being a similarly powerful
option in white. However, I’d argue that these are
also probably the least interesting options
as well given how straightforward and hard to
interact with they are, so if you’re not
playing at a super high power level you
should go with whatever parity breaker feels
most appropriate to you. The important thing
is that you have at least something for this,
some number of cards played with the goal of
converting that cool board that you worked hard
to build up, into a win. With all of that said,
and to crib shamelessly from EDHRECast, one
challenge in navigating parity breakers is
being able to distinguish a card that helps
you win from a win-more card. The goal of
a parity breaker should be to turn a game state
that’s not quite winning into one that wins, but
some cards will only win with a boardstate that
was probably already about to win. For example,
Epic Struggle wins the game outright if you have
20 or more creatures, but there are a ton of cards
that can win off of a board that massive, and
most will be useful in situations with fewer
creatures as well rather than being a four mana
enchantment with no text. Crucible of Fire is a
less extreme example of this—it’s an anthem for a
creature type that’s generally already quite big,
and most dragon decks would probably be better
served by running an additional dragon with useful
abilities instead. Ultimately, the way to navigate
these sorts of cards is to just think about all
the situations in which a given card is useful,
and also the situations where it’s not useful. If
something is a kinda dead card two thirds of the
time, that other third had better be really good.
Parity also exists as a relevant concept outside
of midrange decks, specifically for aggro and
control decks. For an aggro deck, parity is
what you want to avoid—and if your momentum
does come to a bit of a stall as your opponents
catch up on board, you at least want them to be
low enough on life or other resources to be deeply
uncomfortable in their position within the game.
This is the general conceit of a lot of 60 card
burn decks—throw creatures at your opponent’s face
until you can’t anymore, then hope you got your
opponent low enough to finish them off with burn
in time. Control, on the other hand, is similar
to the classical midrange parity plan in the sense
that it’s looking to create and then break it,
but is very different in that control decks will
often create parity by using board wipes or stax
pieces that slow down the table, and then break
parity using carefully picked out cards that are
less affected by these tools. Control decks are
also typically chiefly worried about resource
management—compromises must be made between
how scary the board is allowed to be and how many
control spells are kept in hand for contingencies.
For these reasons, control is sometimes easier
to finish off opponents with than midrange,
since small boards and suppressive methods mean
that less potent finishers can still do the job,
and that winning over the course of several turns
is acceptable. You do still need to think about
the deck’s win plan, though, and balancing that
with the deck’s controlling elements is naturally
going to be part of the challenge. On that note,
let’s talk about removal in a more general sense.
Based on the amount of removal people
seem to run in casual EDH it seems like
a lot of people might not be aware of this,
but if one of your opponents wins the game,
your odds of winning that game actually drop
quite precipitously. You might have a bit of a
hard time pulling off that W. So, seeing as how
this is Snail’s Guide to Winning an EDH Game,
it is my duty to tell you that preventing your
opponents from winning the game is an important
concern that you shouldn’t take lightly. However,
despite my smartassery, I understand why people
tend to run low removal counts. Let’s assume
for a moment that we’re thinking about the
archetypal removal spell—a spell that destroys a
spooky thing on our opponent’s board that may or
may not lead to our demise if left unchecked.
For every removal spell you add to your deck,
you’re increasing your ability to hinder your
opponents, but you’re also subtracting from
slots available to bolster your own gameplan.
For this reason, you can think of these removal
spells as being something that buys you time, at
a cost. As a side effect of this, faster decks
won’t need as many removal spells as slower decks,
and I’m going to demonstrate why that is visually.
Let’s think about the amount of stuff that
needs removing at a given moment. When I
think of really spooky stuff that begins to
happen in a game, it generally starts up small,
where say 10% of the time there will be some
potentially game ending nonsense on a given turn,
but things will pick up for the next few turns
until you’re at the point when there’s gonna
be spooky stuff left and right. The timing and
what exactly comprises Potentially Game Ending
Nonsense will vary with power level, but the
basic concept stays fairly constant and you
can shift around this scale as needed. Let’s say
you’re playing at a somewhat middling power level
where you’re gonna see power plays starting to
trickle out around turn 5, with things getting
really intense by turn 9 or so assuming the game
goes that long. If you’re playing a faster deck,
say one that’s looking to start knocking down
opponents around turn 6, there’s a lot of
stuff that you simply won’t need to deal with,
because your opponents won’t have time to fully
develop it out before you’re threatening
lethal. By contrast, if you’re playing a
slower deck that’s looking to develop a much more
all-encompassing threat a bit later in the game,
there’s a good chance you’ll need to contend
with some threatening plays from your opponents
before you’re able to pull off your win, since
player removal is not an option. You’ll still
want some ways to slow down your opponents in a
faster deck, but you won’t need nearly as many.
Another consideration is that interaction isn’t
always just about stopping your opponents’ win
plans—it can also remove obstacles to
your win plan. With a given Flame Slash,
you could be killing your opponent’s Volo,
Guide to Monsters to prevent them from doing
some dumb shit with it, but you could also be
deleting somebody’s Glissa so you can swing at
them with your offensively large attacker or
getting rid of their Archon of Emeria so you
can have your ridiculous pop-off turn
unimpeded. This sort of flexibility is
also where counterspells really shine—you can
always counter that Jin-Gitaxias or Tergrid,
but you can also counter a board wipe or a removal
spell lobbed at your key creature. I personally
really like counterspells and usually run at least
8 in my decks with blue, and I’ll run more if the
win plan is more fragile, such as one that is
slow and board-based or a combo without backup
options. Counterspells do have their downsides
though—there’s the holding-up-mana problem
where if you hold up mana for a potential
threat and that threat doesn’t materialize,
you’ve effectively wasted mana, as opposed
to a removal spell where you can wait for a
threat to materialize and then deal with it at
your next convenience. Counterspells are still
fantastic and can deal with some higher-powered
threats that are untouchable by normal removal,
but they require a bit more thought to fit into a
game plan, and might not be right for all decks.
Regardless, it’s worthwhile to put in the thought,
and consider what sorts of interaction will best
bolster your win plan, and whether it might be
worth it to play a bit more of a given deck.
I think it bears mentioning that everything I’ve
said so far in this video is meant in the context
of a game where decks are similarly matched in
terms of power level, and where players are on
the same page about what constitutes a fun game
of Magic: the Gathering. The most foolproof way
to win a game of EDH is to obliterate a
bunch of precons with a Godo cEDH deck,
so I guess if that’s what you clicked on the
video for, there you go, but I’d say that sort
of gameplay is not interesting for anybody.
In addition, for any given card that might
be considered a finisher, there will be plenty
of players who aren’t interested in using it,
and others who would rather not play against it,
and navigating that is a key step in having fun
while playing a casual, social format. While
this video is about how to win an EDH game,
my target audience here is less so decks that are
already well-rounded and looking to pump their
power level and more so decks that are doing
some cool things, but are still struggling to
find their way to wins. There’s a good chance
that improving your deck’s ability to win will
make it feel more powerful overall, but my point
here is simply that you should achieve that by
playing to your deck’s strengths and improving
its internal cohesion rather than just windmill
slamming Craterhoof Behemoth or Torment
of Hailfire into it and calling it a day.
I also didn’t really discuss combo in this video
because I feel like combos are often conceptually
more straightforward than other types of win
options since, though you can build a multivalent
combo family that can navigate around 5 different
types of stax effect, on the most basic level
combo decks tend to be more of a yes-or-no
proposition when it comes to winning compared to
a conventional aggro, midrange, or control deck.
I also made a full video about combo awhile back,
and I’ll briefly summarize a couple points from
that video here. Putting a combo in your deck can
be a good way to win a game, but you should accept
that if you throw a combo in your midrange deck,
if that combo is a lot better than your midrange
win plan, you’re not playing a midrange deck,
you’re playing a weird, inconsistent combo deck.
Below higher powers, the best type of combo to put
in your deck will be one that requires some degree
of setup, but setup that fits naturally into the
rest of your deck’s plan, and whose pieces have
alternative use cases in your deck. Combo is
basically synergy taken to the extreme, so combos
should ideally emerge from trying to optimize your
synergies, not from throwing Sanguine Bond
and Exquisite Blood in a random black deck.
To recap some general pointers from earlier,
making your deck do a better job of winning will
often just mean making sure the inputs and outputs
are focused. Keeping your inputs focused typically
just means having enough deck cohesion that your
deck can launch into a game plan off of its first
10 or 15 cards it draws. You can think of this
as having a wide onramp—you want as many cards as
possible that feel good early to give your deck
the best chances of getting into gear. Keeping
your outputs focused means that once your deck
gets up and going, the things it does are ones
that all contribute to a cohesive gameplan that’s
moving in the direction of victory. If you’re
making a deck that does a lot of a particular
thing, such as discarding cards or sacrificing
artifacts, it’s tempting to just throw in all
sorts of cards that have fun effects when those
things happen, but doing that will just add filler
that doesn’t help you win. Wincons don’t exist in
the sense that you’re gonna have a bad time if you
smash together a deck and then throw in a handful
of splashy cards at the end for the purpose of
winning, but put a bit of thought in from the
start of where your deck wants to be going, and
you’ll have a pretty good chance of getting there.